but how about we we derail entirely back
to the discussion about
uh should we talk about the riots in
holland and the civil war coming to the
netherlands yeah
and tie it in with guns because alex is
here and i want to know about
well they don't have guns in guns they
don't no but they could they sure could
they could this is well i don't i don't
know if that would be a good thing or
not
i mean perhaps uh it's a good thing for
individuals to to
have the ability to defend themselves i
think in the context that i'm trying to
say is when people are out in the
streets fighting and you know fighting
you know
there's fear of a civil war maybe we
don't want people escalating the point
the problem is
one side already has guns and they're
using them so
i'm not saying they're using live rounds
in the people in the netherlands but
here's the story
the daily mail says lockdown fury sparks
a third night of violence in holland
with hundreds of protesters looting
shops torching cars and battling police
the netherlands hit by a third night of
riding on monday with clashes in
rotterdam amsterdam in the hog
police and said police said 184 people
had been arrested by tuesday morning
and promised more arrests would be made
hundreds of riders had looted shops
set fires and clashed with police who
responded with water cannons
it comes into the netherlands introduced
a coronavirus curfew
from 9 pm until 4 30 a.m to bring cases
down
now i believe it was uh the mayor of
eindover who said
that we are on the verge of civil war
and i think it's actually
is it up here i don't know they they
change their articles so much here we go
rioters first struck on sunday night in
amsterdam eindhoven what did i call it
handover
eindhoven and multiple other towns
seeming to catch authorities off guard
and prompting warnings from some
politicians
of civil war john joritsma mayor of
eindhoven
warned bluntly that we are on our way to
civil war
they say despite the unrest many
countries in europe are considering
tightening their lockdowns
this is a this is a impossible
conversation an impossible discussion to
be completely honest
people often ask like where's the line
in government
intrusion until you say enough and then
demand a regis of grievances to the
point
where there's clashes right because i
tell you in china they're shoving swabs
of people's butts
at a certain point the line has been
breached right
but for now it is a fact that in this
country the line can never be crossed
there's no line there's no point
there's like you could have a bunch of
people who have no plan thinking they're
going to occupy a building
and that's the revolution it's not but
there's there's there's
i think we're at a point where there's a
global security infrastructure that's
not going to allow for that to happen
so it could all break down at some point
when people just lose it i guess
yeah well in the netherlands this is the
third night
of widespread rioting and violence that
even some local politicians are saying
will continue for days
or weeks they burned down many
testing facilities they're they're
fighting police officers in the street
and
this is predominantly over the lockdown
restrictions and specifically this
curfew because a lot of people are
saying
what does the coronavirus not infect you
under a certain time does the
coronavirus have a bedtime
and there have even been studies showing
that curfews are absolutely pointless
and they do nothing except hinder
daily life and allow the police to have
an excuse to take away your liberties or
your money away from you alex you had
something to say
it's it's complicated yeah because we
can go deep in like the philosophical
discussion on
when you lose like your national
sovereignty
and you start having those civil the the
civil
war sort of clashes and armed resistance
and uh you know what happens when one
side of that
uh when the side of that argument where
where you know the the people who don't
think that their government
has the authority to to sort of rule
over them anymore
um you know what happens when that group
isn't doesn't have any quality of arms
with their their right
for lack of a better term their masters
so
i mean there's there's a real like
philosophical argument to get into
and you see a lot of it in like you in
through portland through
the the the antifa riots um
you know a little bit a bit of it popped
up um
in in dc and i don't know it's it's it's
you know you know i think the the
armament of the people
changes the threshold for when those
people will react violently
and so you look at somewhere like china
and the state is a massive security
state with censorship
control of all weapons there's the
likelihood of an uprising is slim to
none
because the odds are so much against the
people
there there's concentration camps in
china right now in the u.s
it's a bit more precarious because you
have to think about
the amount of pressure on an individual
to make them act and the capability they
have to actually accomplish something
in a place like china or in europe the
ability to accomplish something when you
have an armed state versus an unpopulous
is
slim unless you have critical mass so
the line at which it becomes a civil war
like this this you know
dutch mayor is saying is further away
than is in the united states
in the united states you can get one
crazy guy with powerful weapons
who feels he can actually do something
that's scary to me it is
because we want stability we don't want
instability we're not we're not
currently dealing with people getting
anal anally swabbed but we do
have the curtailing of our freedoms i i
think the question is for the u.s
even with the curtailing of our freedoms
we're still pretty much living in in
luxury
relative to other places yeah but also
against that kind of uh you know
sentiment that you said
in europe all you need is a truck and
and there have been incidences where
there have been
deadly events that have been far more
impactful than shootings in the united
states because of some crazy person
saying i'm just going to run a whole
bunch of people over
with a truck so you know that's another
sentiment here that we need to
understand
but what i mean is if you like if in the
us they started doing mandatory anal
swabbing
i imagine things would break down really
fast a lot of social justice warriors
would probably
like that probably okay yeah and so
maybe sure if you want to make the
argument that maybe in cities things
would just go along like we've seen
what's going on with new york they just
go for it but think about that the
cities are unarmed
for the most part people in the cities
are not are completely unarmed
and would just go with whatever they're
told then you
you i mean just look at the the militias
in this country and the groups that are
armed
they tend not to be living in cities so
either they're moving out for more
freedom
or they're more self-reliant and more
you know don't tread on me
you look at places like the netherlands
the point i'm trying to make is
you require very few people and much
less
rage and oppression among for an armed
population to rise up and say enough
whereas in the netherlands you're going
to have people who are like what am i
going to do about it i can't do anything
i'm on my own
but eventually when you get thousands of
people in the street that's when things
when that line is crossed so you need
more people
and more oppression for an unarmed
population to finally snap and revolt
which i think is a very simple equation
and explains why governments don't want
people to have guns
especially democrats don't want people
have to go to have guns which is why i
think
you know what you're you know doing uh
uh alex is
is it's gonna be interesting i guess the
way people say it is the cat's out of
the bag gun control is over
yeah can't can't do sorry i hit the
table
can't do much about it it's it's you
know people and
the the the kicker is people have been
making guns in their homes for
the last hundred years before the advent
of 3d printing
now what's the laws with that because i
know some people have you know
don't really know how clear it is what
they can do what can't they do illegally
right so on the federal level it is
entirely legal if you are able to
federal if you are federally able to
possess a gun so you're not a felon
you're not a domestic abuser
um there are a couple other criteria in
there that i'm not
on the top of the top of the mind you
can't be a drunkard
uh no you can be i don't know when you
buy a gun it asks you are you a drunkard
and if you put yes they said guy you
can't have a gun no for real yeah yeah
i'm not gonna reform that you have to
yeah aggressive or public intoxication
no it just says are you a drunkard or
habitual drinker that must be an old law
yeah and i think there's also something
oh are you addicted to alcohol or any
other substance
right yeah yeah and i think there's also
another section about psychological
issues right
or you can't beat your wife yeah or your
husband
right so there are a couple criteria
that will uh
will disbar you from from owning a
firearm
but if you're able to own it then you
should be able to make it
um you know without any real
hang-ups um mail order parts and
straight to your door
what can't you manufacture locally what
parts
um there aren't any at the moment
you can make a full auto you can you can
you can legally make your own oh okay no
i see
sorry i understand you cannot legally
make a make a machine gun
because you cannot legally possess a
machine gun right yeah all right the law
actually stops the manufacturing machine
guns that's it right
you can old grandfathered in machine
guns right right so there was a machine
gun registry
before they were forbidden um and you
can
own those they're very expensive
somewhere in the realm of like twenty
thousand dollars for one
what if you had like a gun with 30
barrels that filed
fired 30 rounds the exact same time
that's volley fire
which is legal under the law really yeah
oh i didn't know that
it's not just thing as a dumb question
yeah there was a revolver that came out
recently that has
two barrels you fire two i think two 38
specials out of it i i could be wrong or
two 222's um but with a with one pull of
the trigger you get
two bullets out of two barrels so only
if you want to transfer a firearm do you
have to contact the atf and get a serial
number for that firearm is that correct
uh the jury is out on that one okay
because the atf usually changes its mind
right uh
more than politicians flip-flop right
and they're all over the place with
their definitions which are very
confusing they're they're kind of
understandings and their their legal
arguments are
kind of all over the place right so so
to get into the nuts a little bit it's
manufacturing exclusively for personal
use
not for sale or distribution so if you
make it with the intent to give it away
you've committed a felony if you make it
with the intent to sell it you've
committed a felony if you make it with
the intent to use it solely for yourself
for whatever you
are using it for then you're fine wow so
i pulled it up
uh i just googled it and we have it's
it's t-rex smallarms.com
arsenal firearms af 2011 double barrel
pistol
in 38 super yup so it is a handgun with
two barrels it's four thousand dollars
five inch slide double barrel
semi-automatic 38 super caliber
fires both barrels with one pull of the
trigger now why would you want that
because it looks cool i mean i'm not
saying you shouldn't have it you can
flex
on your friends with the same gun but
only one barrel
look i'm cooler than you well no but
look but i think about the question the
left often asks is like why would anyone
need this
is there is there first i understand the
immediate response is
it doesn't matter i don't need a reason
i have a second amendment right to own
arms
that i get but is there like a real
functional or tactical reason to having
volley fire or double barrel
you know one trigger pull two bullets
well i mean it it
you're putting twice the amount of of
projectile into whatever you're shooting
at
so if you're you know if you're sh if
you're hunting bear with an ar-15
you're gonna want more than one round
but you probably shouldn't be hunting
bear with an ar-15
so we talked about this though we talked
about um full auto is actually bad
tactically you know uh tactically
generally speaking it it just wastes a
lot of ammo
uh in in most like a military type
engagement you're going to be shooting
at an individual target
um there is an argument for it where
you're talking about suppressing fire
coming from machine guns um but when you
when you start getting into like fully
auto out of a 30 round magazine it's
kind of
not great like it's it's useful for the
military there's a reason that they have
it if you you know you're in a pinch and
you just
click the button over you know don't
they call it spray and pray
yeah yeah yeah um i just wanted to do a
clarification also when nancy pelosi
lately had said that she wanted crew man
machine guns on these things it's
they're actually called crew served
weapons my friend that was in the army
was like please
tell everyone well we just we just read
what ken cuccinelli said
you know and he said crew men to machine
guns yeah he's part of the patriarchy
patriarchy so uh crew served well you
can't make full auto
right but that's not that's full auto is
not even a good thing anyway
so it seems kind of redundant yeah i
mean again there's there's an argument
for it
you know if you can control it then you
can be accurate with it and that's the
training thing which you need exposure
to train with it
um so there are arguments for and
against um
are there guns that will automatically
fire when they target the person
uh you're talking like an automated
turret yeah like if you turn it and it
sees the
the person or the target or the deer or
whatever that then
it will fire when it sees it kind of
there was a company called tracking
point they made a really fun optic
um and they i i think a later iteration
they built it into a full
rifle platform where you're hunting and
you see the deer and you want to you
want to hit it
at a specific point to get uh you have
to clean kill on it
um and so it would wait until you would
pull the trigger
and then you would like adjust the your
your position
so you would line up properly and once
it lined up properly it would fire
um it's been it's been years since i've
seen this
yeah and i i don't know if i'm
remembering it exactly
so don't quote me well you want to make
sure you don't wound a deer because
they're going to run away and they're
going to be injured and they're going to
be suffering there's a specific place on
the deer
i think in the in the lung heart area
correct me if i'm wrong that you have to
if you shoot once it's it's a it's a
pretty good sign that you're
it's going to be a short clean kill
and and the animal is not going to
suffer right thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you